Berger was really interesting to me
because it's the 60 year old fast-food
chain that's kind of always been dwarfed
in the shadows of McDonald's but they
had this interesting private nerdy CEO
who started when he was only 32 and I
really just wanted to get to know him
and figure out how he turned this chain
around he had engineered the sale of it
just a few years before revamped it
through cost-cutting through viral
marketing and a will to try to win so
Daniel Schwartz was this finance guy at
3G he was the one who originally thought
it was a good idea to acquire the
company and they did it for four billion
in debt and they've really seen the
investment grow compared to a lot of the
other investments that have been food
world I wanted to understand what
happened with Burger King and why that
turnover was so successful comparatively
and to figure out what burfi really is
doing differently and how they're able
to be growing so much with comparatively
far smaller budgets then you know
McDonald's and I'm gonna take you
through some of their biggest milestones
from the year in February they spent
several million dollars
on a 45 second super will ad that
featured Andy Warhol slowly methodically
opening and unwrapping and eating a
whopper
it became the most Google searched term
of the Superbowl and definitely paid
dividends for them later that month
Daniel Schwartz was promoted to
executive chairman while also being
redeployed at 3 G's other investment
Kraft Heinz which wasn't going so well
at the time and then Jose still a
longtime employee a Burger King became
CEO so the next month I went down to
Burger King headquarters in Miami and
became the first journalist to try the
impossible oper no one at the time
really knew that was coming and it
launched a few weeks later the Chris
penis was definitely the same the
patties do look different but it was
really good and it definitely tasted
like meat there definitely wasn't a
difference really that you could see
side-by-side or taste for that matter
but you know that's the flavor science
that goes into all this
so my story came out on April 1st the
same day that the impossible whopper
launched as well in a few small
locations in the Midwest but it quickly
rolled out to more than 7,000 locations
across the US and became the biggest
plant-based launch that we've seen to
date going into it people really didn't
think that impossible would be able to
service 7,000 locations but Burger King
proved it wrong and with some shortages
along the way it became a huge huge push
for the same part of my reporting
process was interviewing Daniel in New
York and here's what he had to say about
this pivotal year for Burger King how
many you know brands that have been
around for 50-plus years bro 10 Corey
10% Franklin we still like feel like you
can still do a whole lot better and I'm
very confident that we have the right
team the right leadership to be doing
even better in the long run by November
all this frenzy had started to gain some
negative attention as well and a lawsuit
came out alleging that the impossible
whopper is grilled on the same griddles
as the whopper meaning that the beef
allegedly gets mixed in through the oils
and the juices when cooking it's gonna
be something really interesting that
we're gonna be watching and to see how
it continues to play out Burger King is
owned by restaurant Brands International
which also owns Popeyes which had the
crazy fried chicken sandwich lunch this
year but you know going in Burger King
sales are up close to 10 percent
system-wide this year and the impossible
whopper is definitely a huge driver of
that
[Music]
you